ouais
on
on se rend aujourd'hui à paris saclay
invest c'est notre première
participation ici et on est ici pour
présenter cultive donc cultive c'est
donc c'est une start up qui va permettre
en fait aux particuliers de reproduire
chez lui des fruits et des légumes frais
directement dans sa cuisine
donc notre premier produit c'est basile
qui permet de faire pousser en fait des
herbes aromatiques directement sur le
plan de travail de la cuisine et sans
effort utilise des techniques un petit
peu particulière de culture sans terre
un éclairage led et dans un objet
connecté qui va vous permettre de vous
rapprocher un petit peu de la nature
d'avoir des conseils de jardinage des
conseils de cuisine et qui vous aider à
réussir en fait enfin vos tentatives de
culture
aujourd'hui on a des avis des super
retour ça fait vraiment plaisir en fait
de pitch est son projet on avait cinq
minutes pour le pitch est aujourd'hui
est de faire un petit peu de parcourir
la salle du regard et de voir les gens
qui acquiesce parce que c'est un sujet
en fait qui est très qui vraiment
d'actualité
on parle d'agriculture urbaine on parle
de faire soi même on parle de produits
ultra frais et on parle de cuisine alors
ça fait huit mois qu'on travaille à
temps plein avec mon associé alexandre
et six mois qu'on travaille à l'usiné au
un atelier de prototypage dans paris où
on a pu produire donc ce prototype là
ainsi que ses 29 petit frère qui sont en
tête chez des particuliers aujourd'hui
et avec ses retours d'expériences où on
perfectionne notre produit dans le but
de l'industrialiser demain et c'est la
raison de notre présence ici on est à la
recherche du financement pour
l'industrialiser alors en fait déjà nous
comment on est arrivé dans ce territoire
on a travaillé tous les deux pendant
pendant quatre ans avec alexandre et
ensuite j'ai fait un master spécialisé
entrepreneuriat donc était central
parier
et avec l'essec vraiment on a trouvé
dans cet écosystème de centrale paris
l'accès à des réseaux le réseau peps
nous a permis d'avoir notre première
subvention et ensuite d'autres
subventions aussi lié à cet écosystème
paris saclay donc c'est grâce à eux
qu'on est là aujourd'hui
tout simplement le but évidemment pour
nous c'est de commercialiser notre
produit pour la fin d'année prochaine
donc des préventes à partir de parution
du printemps et une commercialisation
via des réseaux spécialisés à partir de
la fin de l'année prochaine et avait un
gros coup à noël c'est un achat qui est
très cadeaux